very exciting the sheenia this is a
truly truly historical event first time
we've ever landed a probe on a comet and
it's it writes many rights up there with
being the first man to send into space
and landing a human on the moon now
we've got a probe so next time around
we're gonna round up some volunteers and
hopefully send a group of folks over to
a time yes the coolest nASA has
specialized more in manned missions
hasn't Robin unmanned ones such as this
one but I just like the envious that
perhaps NASA doesn't actually manage
this first actually you're correct i was
a european space agency leading the
efforts i think there is some NASA
involvement but I think anytime you have
it first a regardless of a which country
or which group is involved i think it's
a it's a giant step forward to take it
work from a phrase from the armstrong
for humankind I mean I think we all
applauded when questioned I think I
Russian into space for the first time
and then we all caught it when the US
and an American to the moon for the
first time so now we're here applauding
when the European sending a probe for
the first time to the surface of a
comment I think that's great yet in the
last hour or so Hosea News's emerged the
perhaps that everything has gone
smoothly and I'm not even convinced that
perhaps fillet has attached itself
securely to this commenter you must be
able to understand how concerning that
must be for the mission services
absolutely you gotta understand that a
dead a comment has very low mass so it
has a very weak gravitational field so
when you land probe any type of propene
to a comment you have to shoot it
harpoon and my understanding is that
harpoon must may not have taken to the
comet and so it may have landed softly
and not entirely secured and it may even
have bounced one or 12 or two times and
landed a couple of times but from what
our understanding is that it is under
of the comment it may be tilted or
somewhat but it is still on the surface
so I think the mission objective thus
far has been has been reached